I'm speaking to mr.
Alf shields who worked in the like
workshops on the sydney harbour bridge.
When you worked on the on the
harbour bridge for dorman long. Mr.
Shields. Do you remember. Did you come out
here from england specially to get the
job. Now. No i didn't
really i came out in 1926.
Just to find
a new home for my mother and family. And
do you remember getting the job done
and long as i do. I remember my mother
packed up some lunch for me and
she said you might try again at the harbour
bridge and might be some vacancies. So
i caught the tram and then the ferry to
miss and sprint and i had to wait outside
an office that has sat in charge of mr.
Martin. One of the angin is
at work under the bridge
and i saw her eight or nine chaps
coming out from the door with. What i
would say crestfallen faces and i thought
well that they're not putting anybody on
today. So i haven't much happened and then
it came my turn to go in and. Without
going into too many details. Mr martin
asked me if i knew anything about bridge
building and i said not really so. I
said i have been on small bridges
when with the who are engineers in
the british army but of course those
small bridges were just child's play. And
i'm afraid i didn't learn much. But i
like this there. So what it is
a do give me the job anyway.
So anyway he said well it's
a. For being so forthright that you
admit you know nothing about the bench.
I'll keep here
a three months. Trial and few don't
know anything but in three months.
I'm not hoping you would have to go. So he
said you can start to morrow. And i was
overjoyed how going back to the place
where i lived at bond i and torrid
money and of course we made preparations
that i shouldn't miss missed the early
train. So i could be there at mrs.
Point at 7:30. The next morning.
And you did take up the job.
Yes i took up the job i was introduced
to but i only remember has been
frank she that was his nickname and
i was very pleased to be able to
summon her parents
a new all their answers to everything
connected with that the cranes and dogma and
. Work in bars and the talk that it was
your job while you were working at the
workshops there but i was more or less so.
I was classified as a document. Under
a train she at that time and
that i found that he was
a most. Willing worker
and. Willing to show me
a pic hanging that was required
in the way of knots and
a way to sling happy that is without
any any danger to those working
in the workshops. So you would
actually sling and dogman for the
drivers who handled the plates in
the workshop where. You such a and
b. I might add the crane drivers
a course. I'd get the same train driver
week after week month after month
and what we got to know again. And although
the claims of so high up. You could
really. Pick out the outlines
of his face just sort of
a blur. But you knew that it was the same
chat and where to talk to each other
in sign language and at times it was quite
funny and humorous and what do you say
in sign language. Well they the
client either would look down on the
. Perhaps
a rather large girder and shake
his head which meant to tell us
that when he heis up. What angus going
to be happy. Alec might be dangerous
and. We but shake hands and pull
out a ten bob note or perhaps
a pound that as much as to say we're
back to it's okay. And he'd pull out his
wallet and. And indicate that it was
quite ok. And then when he lifted up
and found that they carried
a little it up even let both
hands. How used to pretend
to pull out
a pound note and talk to us and things like
that occurred. Quite often during that
day and seemed to add a bit of
a bit of humor to the whole situation
although not deterring us from from doing the
work that we were told to do. Do you
remember any dangerous moments that
happened while you were there. Yes
there was one occasion when we had
a curtain to turn round for the drill as
it had been drilled and our job was to set
it right over so that the. Who am in job.
Stunned by the drill as what but take all
the rough edges off the holes and on
one occasion the highest started working.
And my hands were underneath that until
a thick chains and tighten
up all the time and i looked
a bit afraid she said i didn't call
out to him that he saw apparently
just in time
a look of fear in my eyes and hear mediately
blow his whistle and the ropes and
chains second and i found that my hands
although you could see that they'd been
trapped. They were not hurt. They were just
barely. Superficially bruised and i was
very very thankful and i sort of get
this band called fancy as probably
the most alert dog man that i
would ever hope to bump against
to member any other incidents where people
got hurt in the workshops. Yes there was
another occasion when
a trailer. One of the jealous much
burned senses and he slipped and
he fell between the drill and his trousers
got caught and ripped ripped off and
in the bent he lost one of his testicles
and i remember the anders chaps coming as
a token white and i learnt subsequently
that he had only lost one of his testicles
and that his married life but not then
have been granted. Hopeless in that sense.
Then as he did have another child that he.
Yes i did hear that he had a spot had
a child after that and i think that most
of the chaps in the workshop were very
pleased about that. You were involved
in any. In any escapes lucky escapes
yourself. Yes. Only one is ah well the
band i've already mentioned of course but
i was going towards the
mapping shop on some some
business or other which i forget. And i was
making my way there because one of the
foremen and you mean the template
loved you. Yes the template
lifetime. It was
a huge spirit and where all the plans
were laid out to be ready for the
boilermakers and we have
a not very far from the door
of the template shop when
a heist. Disengaged itself from the
horses and came down. I suppose
. September or eighty five feet. Whatever
distance was and it completely bad itself
in the ground. About ten feet from where
we're standing and i recall that the
fireman looked at me and i looked at him
and we didn't say anything but i must have
thought as he must have thought as hard it
that we were both very lucky that there
weren't any closer when lights for got hit
hit by it and would have been attracted
to member the working conditions in the
shop that it was it noisy was it dirty what
was that it was like.
Well yes of course. In
a workshop at that nature.
You had steel pilings steel
a shavings from the trailers. And dirt
and dust and and stuff like that.
Good but to be. In any type of workshop
where they would get the same kind of
conditions and as we were handling
stay there all day long when
we couldn't wear gloves because they
impeded the usefulness of your hands in
fixing the the chain. So
i had to steal horses
. To such an extent that we
improvised by getting me some
stout stout hash in. Hash and. Much
of the same texture was a as a as
a concept about nine inches square
whatever made it to slits and it
and we were able to put these on and they
took the brunt and the rough notes right
to stay you know where are handling and i
think we had to make two or three to last
a whole week. And by that method. Lee
didn't get our hands time with the sharp
pieces of steel and the sharp edges
of the courtesies and plates.
Do you remember any of the machines working
around you or in the in the shop or in
the dejection shops. Yes. That was
a guillotine at the end of the shop.
Which was it were and of course
all day long. It only worked when
they had to cut stair plates to
a certain size and when the
nissan was working. Cutting
steel so to insist check that tries
to shake and i often wondered
. What would happen if they'd had half
a dozen of those hussein's working all
at once. I'm quite sure that they their
effect would have been like
a small earthquake. Did you ever see
any river thing going on around
the place. Yes has not attacked.
I went went to there happens to
have your workshop. I'm on occasion
and my younger brother have
a sense of dentally that put on action
a pantheist i think as an apprentice paul
and i stay out of work of some kind.
He was only
a very young chap and he was engaged
in. Throwing up the hot rivets to
a chat about him about ten feet above him
and then the chap who took the rivets
from him. What place them into
rabbit hole and the river to stand with
people worked with it. The white hot or
that hot rivets
a say about required and that was only
time i saw the riveting being done because
i'd gone up to see my brother to ask if he
was going to do any overtime so that i'd
know if he wasn't on my farrier
about that you know where he was
. Do you remember the times. When any of
the incidents you remember around the
workshops at all. Was
a seal. Do you get put off the harbour
bridge. You know i left on my own accord
. I had heard that they have
a job for me working with the aryan
nation commission in in griffith.
So i thought it would be
a change and i would say that more of new
south wales. So i left at dawn and longs
i think i've got a. How
can a letter from mr.
Martin in the buyout
if it's in the way of
a reference to say the great and the heart
beats for us for so many months. I think
it was eighteen months altogether. And
then i left to go onto this job and
i was only there about three months and i
discovered that they were putting chaps
off. So this up i wrote were these
sad to me i'm afraid our police said
that they're putting off all the single men
only keeping on the mad men. So i said
i said i suppose i don't have to go
dataset and got another job so i got
my last paycheck from those people.
And i like them to to set me where i
managed to get work painting
houses and i remember very well
on one occasion i was painting the
house and i was up the ladder in the
gutter. Rather i think about it was
a double extension ladder and i
was right up to the top and that
the chaps taught i came out. They can't
communicate me the job in the first place.
Heh heh i owned a racehorse and
his daughter came out in rather
a hurry and she shook the level at the
bottom. And i thought she was going to tell
me something about this racehorse but she
said miss alone hasn't cut the bridge
after all it was done by an army
officer. And i said well. I was
too far up above the ground to reply to
her that. When she went inside. I thought
to myself it's had all she
was going to tell very it's
a nearly knocked me off the ladder. But
at the time i was very upset. Tell
teller and i've the fact that some
army officer had cut the ribbon as
a sort of bravado act and i think it all
fit in with some kind of political stuff
happens. Going on at that time. Where did
you go to work after that when did you.
Next get
a job.
It was
a sales it's fifty years later now and you
worked on building the bridge. What do
you think of the idea of putting extra
lines on it and i don't really think it's
a good idea
a good idea at all. In
laws in my ways and one.
It could be
a very tragic mistake in the sense that
two more lines would would mean two more
lots of lines of cars going through
impose their actions and it would appear
that. Much more traffic and.
Much more air pollution
would take place because a lot of
people with extra people would use
a bridge. Knowing that they better
extra lines but but but surely
a big set was designed for what it was.
For the purpose of carrying carpet
which in in the early days was trams
and rather a tactic. Which is now
a rabbi and bridge. Bus
traffic. Surely their badges on
the page might very well be
a spa. Part by by adding terex
to lines that the whole concept
was built as
a bridge and if you're going to do that
the harbour bridge. Why not. There's
a pretty big bridge in the
whole world. Just to get
a pier extra cars going across in both
directions. It doesn't seem to me to be
a good idea at all. Thank you. Is
to our shield. Do you remember the
accuracy with which the job was
done. Well yes of course when the
steel girders came from the template room
and the boilermakers had their job to do
and then of course our job was to take
the boilermakers. Stay out of sheets.
I wanted to drills to be drilled.
And on not very often. Of course on
very rare occasions. Someone had blundered
and the steel holes may have been in the
wrong places. And that whole steel
sheet was then trying to get
towards the harbour put on
a ship and dumped in the middle of the
harbor and happily i could say that while i
was on the beach and i wasn't there for
the whole time that it was being built.
Just a few
a few months perhaps twelve months. I.
I only saw turkey's ins where errors
had been made. And. I suppose a member
diamonds get shot. If he was in
a position to bit to be able to put some
party or something in the holes and
painted over to make it look as open as
okay. That thing of course never would have
occurred on the hop if it's but as i say
when missiles were made the whole lot was
dumped in the middle of
a harbor. Do you member any rivets
being cut out. No no i don't remember
anything at that nature her in that or to
him what the working conditions were like
in the shops. But their working conditions
were such that at 4:50 our police were
black and you had ten minutes to wash your
hands and to wash and we had plenty of
water there because you turn the
tap on dipped your hands in
a big bucket of soft soap wash your hands
tired and then by that time they would
have arrived at millicent's point and you
get onto the ferry boat and so make your
way home and as far as the contestants but
their players to just sit and anywhere.
Eat
a sandwiches after washing their hands of
course because by hand and stare and stare
or shavings and steel spent as would be
around and it's makes sure that they didn't
swallow any of those. Do you remember what
the floor was like what was it like was
it windy there for there were all the
pictures i've seen the walls only come down
so far and it was
a dirt floor i mean i was wonder what
it was like when it was windy in the
workshops. And yes there was
a flaw throughout the whole workshops the
heavy shot and also the like shop and
as far as
a wind was concerned. Bear in mind that
the steel shavings those that couldn't be
swept up in. And place in banks for
disposal but trent into the ground and by
by virtue of the fact that
a lot of all of this used to show up in
the drills and he used the germs in the
stair plates that the ground became
fairly solid and firm and i can't i
can't recollect any time of bang and
convenience but dust flying around there never
was any dust cloud as far as i can
remember. Yes i have opt-in being asked
what i felt. Like working on the
bridge. Did i throw my chest out
and say yes i worked on the beach or i
was working on the beach. Well of course
everybody had seen that afternoon's
picture of the bridge the drawing itself
which looked
a very very beautiful affair. And
one could be sure i said that the.
There chaps on the drawing boards could
see in their innermost eye. What that
beautiful page was going to present to
the public. And. It did make us feel
rather proud to work on the bridge because
we knew that it was worth our job ever
come by passengers and be the means of
conveying people from one part of sydney to
the other in quick time to members
talking with the others about being
glad that you got the tender. Yes i
remember on the carrier that one day
a chap assigned to me. It's
a bit lucky that we've got time on long
to build in the biz because the americans
putting attend and. If they've won won the
tender and started work there i wonder
what kind of age where we would have had
what it would have been at the same.
Symmetrical proportions and the same period.
It's very hard to say then. But with it all
very glad in that sense that an english
firm had got it.